Don Williamson yo man I don't know you
we've never met somebody got to tell you
like yo man you got to get in shape
because you're going to keep getting
hurt if you're out of shape I don't
think the coach has enough power to tell
you what to do I don't think David
Griffin who's A friend of mine has
enough power to tell you what to do I'm
so blessed for Moses Malone told me to
get my fat ass in shape and made me lose
50 pounds it changed the whole dynamic
of my life I hope you don't take this
the wrong way I want you to be a great
basketball player I've been in your
shoes being very talented being
overweight and like I say I thank God
every day for Moses rest in peace you're
playing the Moses role for Zion I would
love to let me tell you something I've
seen dozens guys eat their way out of
the NBA it can happen quickly because
once you start getting hurt you're gonna
keep getting hurt my first contract was
four years two million dollars I got in
shape for two million dollars you're
gonna make another 500 million dollars
all you gotta do is get in shape